hey guys welcome back to reality check
so Diablo 3 isn't again yes the ultimate
evil edition means blizzards dungeon
reading sim is now playable on pretty
much everything Xbox one ps4 this
toaster probably and for me you know
this is no bad thing as it gives me
another excuse to go and collect yet
more loot and speaking of loot check at
the sweet loot bag I grabbed from the
office right next to Marc's desk the
socks of strength I'll hold on to these
aha shorts of ever Sprint's +10 speed -
three smell oh my goodness
could it be do i behold with my eyes the
one and only [ __ ] mask of ultimate
silence you know what I think I'm gonna
put that back
but rummaging through colleagues things
and questioning everything you thought
you knew about them aside collecting
loot is a really enjoyable and rewarding
experience but why why do we love to
pick up loot
Diablo borderland Skyrim also basically
any MMO you can think of all these games
are great at regularly giving us sweet
sexy loops as we progress along her
adventures and with good reason
getting our grubby mitts on desirable
items does make us happy but research
suggests is not so much the getting of
the item that delivers the rush it's
actually more about the anticipation of
more loot to come but delivers the
biggest pleasure response and encourages
us to keep playing so what is going on
inside our mushy human brains then well
as is usually the case when it comes to
our motivation and decision-making the
brain chemical and neurotransmitter
dopamine has a big role to play dopamine
is kind of the celebrity amongst train
signaling chemicals it does a whole load
of different things but it's most famous
for its ability to stimulate the
pleasure centers within the brain during
a whole load of different behaviors
including reward motivated behaviors
like loot gathering for example when we
encounter something we like be it
delicious food in real life or a
powerful new weapon in Diablo our brain
releases dopamine which makes us feel
good but that's not the end of the story
if this happens enough times we start to
associate seeing an item chest with the
prospect of more loot so even the mere
idea of a new chest can cause the
release of dopamine
this is known as operant conditioning by
way of positive reinforcement and is
being demonstrated experimentally in
studies with monkeys not monkeys playing
Diablo mind you although I would totally
watch that now definite human being
Wolfram Schultz and his team for the
University of Freiburg and Switzerland
demonstrated that when monkeys were
conditioned to associate to light or
sound with food their brains would
produce dopamine when presented with
just the light or sound even without the
accompanying food they concluded that
this showed it was the anticipation of
the food that made them feel good much
like the anticipation we feel for more
loot this only works however if the
payout to the food in the monkeys case
or the loot in ours is unpredictable but
regular enough that we don't give up all
hope and get frustrated so as a result
looting games like Diablo is distributed
with a degree of randomness it's placed
based on algorithms so you never know
what you're gonna get but with enough
chance that you'll get something really
good to keep you interested it's
actually quite similar to the experience
you can have with a slot machine in a
casino every chest you open is kind of
like the pool of a handle sometimes you
get nothing of value often you get a
small payoff but occasionally you get a
really great reward it's the potential
of this that gets the dopamine
production going and keeps us searching
for the next loot drop
now as discussed in a previous episode
how to make a great game can psychology
help the key to a great game is creating
the experience of cognitive flow that
I'm in the zone state where the ideal
balance exists between challenge and
reward resulting in the desire to keep
on playing now I think it's clear that
in games like Diablo Borderlands and the
like grabbing loot definitely there's a
law for creating this feeling of flow
but what about the psychology of
collecting things in general well long
term reality check viewers might
remember episode 3 why do we collect
games I investigated the psychology of
why we like to hold on to things now I'm
not convinced that any of the ideas I
discussed in that episode really play a
role in loot collection because
ultimately when it comes to items we are
extremely fickle as soon as I find the
socks of greater strength this once
cherished item will be sold without a
second thought you see once again it's
not about the item it's about the
promise of more something better down
the road so tell me about your
experiences of collecting loot also do
you plan to revisit diablo 3 or perhaps
plate for the first time on ps4 and Xbox
one let me know in the comments now next
week I'm gonna be away on holiday but
the super smart and genuine psychology
degree holder Lucy James will be taking
the reality check reins in my absence so
you will not want to miss that episode
I'll be back the week after though with
something extra special for all you
eSports fans so I'll see that
you